Every time that Donald Trump mentions chloroquine,
every time someone associated with Donald
Trump mentions chloroquine, reporters should
start asking, do you have a personal or financial
interest in this drug becoming the preferred
treatment for coronavirus?
Does anyone in the Trump administration, to
your knowledge, have any such financial interests?
Now, why am I meant mentioning this?
I mentioned it first, because there is almost
always some financial incentive with this
administration, not just with Trump, but with
people around him.
But I also mention it because a major manufacturer
of chloroquine once paid Donald Trump's former
personal lawyer, Michael Cohen, who's now
in jail to get access to Donald Trump.
Remember, back in the Michael Cohen days,
we found out that one of the things you could
do if you had a bunch of money and you wanted
to buy influence was you could go and you
could give money to Michael Cohen, and that
would get you face time with Donald Trump.
One of the largest manufacturers of chloroquine
is Novartis Pharmaceuticals.
Novartis once paid Michael Cohen a million
dollars for so-called health care policy insight
when Trump was elected in 2016.
Now, health care policy insight is just political
code for peddling access because Michael Cohen
knows nothing about health care policy.
He was Trump's henchman who set up hush money
payments to Trump's mistresses.
Cohen, of course, is now in prison, but Novartis
is very much involved with Donald Trump's
coronavirus response.
They have now donated or at least announced
the donation.
Always have to be clear about that.
Of hundred and thirty million doses of chloroquine
to try on coronavirus patients, Trump and
everyone around him have been pushing this
drug, which is one of dozens of drugs with
potential benefits when it comes to coronavirus.
Although increasingly it's not clear that
that's going to pan out.
So that's why we have to ask about the financial
incentives.
Check-out economist, not doctor economist
Peter Navarro here saying, hey, I'm a social
scientist than I can tell you.
This stuff works.
Question I like you.
I like you.
Go to four-point.
You're getting a waterfall.
You're saying a second opinion here.
What are your qualifications to weigh in on
medicine more than Dr. Anthony Fauci?
Why should we listen to you and not Dr. Foushee?
Well, let me suggest, John, that later in
the day you have William Grace on another
famous doctor in the city of New York.
He has he can talk eloquently about this.
But, John, there's doctors disagree about
things all the time.
My qualifications in terms of looking at the
science is that I'm a social sciences p_h_d_.
And I understand how to read statistical studies,
whether it's in medicine, the law economics.
Why, I'm sorry, that doesn't qualify you to
treat patients.
You know, if I hang out.
Judge John, John, John, John, John.
Now, this is an entire other discussion.
But social science is not science in the way
that medicine is science.
There is a big debate to be had about social
science as a science versus a humanity.
That's not the discussion today.
Social science is not medical science.
And the point is, everyone seems desperate
to claim that they know chloroquine works
to treat Corona virus.
So, of course, is this proof that there is
a financial incentive for Trump to promote
this one possible treatment over others?
No, this isn't proof, but it is yet again,
another instance of a financial entanglement
surfacing after just a little bit of investigation.
Novartis having PEUT previously paid Michael
Cohen for access to Donald Trump.
Everything's for sale.
The my pillow guy makes some masks and loves
Trump and he gets to speak at a coronavirus
press briefing.
Gordon Sunland bought himself an ambassadorship.
Not actually rare in politics in general.
I would love to know who else might have made
financial moves around chloroquine, whether
it's Rudy or, you know, Dr. Oz. Trump's kids
or whoever.
Now, because it's going to become a story,
I want to say a little bit more about this.
It has been revealed that Donald Trump has
a sort of indirect financial connection to.
One company that makes chloroquine, The New
York Times, reports that as of last year,
Trump reported that his three family trusts
each had investments in a Dodge and Cox mutual
fund, whose largest holding was in Sanofi,
which is another manufacturer of chloroquine.
I actually don't think that's the real story
for a guy as rich as Trump.
This is this is not really a huge thing.
You know, I think the chloroquine thing is
not so much Trump's personal, financial, financial
interest, which is through a mutual fund in
a trust.
It's companies are paying for access.
Many of Trump's donors and allies have ties.
This is a little too small in my mind to be
the story.
But we will see what turns up.
And we should all be asking what is the financial
connection here?
Because it seems pretty clear that on a number
of different fronts, there appears to be one.
Thursday, 2:00 p.m. Eastern.
David Pakman show membership explosion.
We lost three hundred and eighty nine members
in March because people are struggling because
of the virus.
We get it.
So what we're doing is this Thursday.
An email is going to go out to all of our
newsletter subscribers with a one time use
coupon code for a massive membership discount
on our Web site.
The reason is we want to try to pull back
some of those large numbers of members that
we lost.
So sign up for my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
Thursday, 2:00 p.m. Eastern, 11:00 a.m.
Pacific, you'll be notified about this massive
membership special.
I invite you in.
In the meantime, keep me posted.
How's your quarantine going?
I'm on Twitter at The David Pakman Show David
Pakman.
Dot com.